where i'm going with this is
guns
because uh out here in the middle of
nowhere do you shoot the bear is it no
no
okay no but that's where i'm going the
point i'm making is
to wrap up the you know the other we're
talking about music and freedom
my attitude is i will not go to these
venues in in new york uh jack murphy a
good friend of uh a good friend of ours
and
end of the show he's been doing these
events and he said we're going to do
ours on the other side of the river
because they've got vaccine mandates in
new york and we can do it at a venue
with that one
i i i believe
maybe you can't play a stadium because
they're all mandating it but stand up
for something right so for us we have
this space and we can do almost anything
so we'll have a shooting range and we're
gonna be putting on concerts and we're
gonna be hosting events that's great
where we can just say you know screw it
there's also pork fest up in new
hampshire that has you know it's all
about freedom and they've got the free
state project a bunch of bitcoin
conferences there's a bunch of free
festivals there's a bunch of people
coming together there is a mass
awakening with protests happening all
over the world in huge record numbers
that are absolutely incredible to see
filling the streets for blocks on down
and i just had this idea randomly tim i
think we should do a parody of the blair
witch project we go to the woods that
they filmed it in but we have firearms
so if someone messes with us we just
shoot him and then that's the end of the
movie it's like okay that's that's what
happens when you're armed when you're
able to defend yourself
hurt you or kill you right we wouldn't
have had a two hour terrifying movie it
would be like two minutes long they're
like oh we're walking in the woods oh
there's someone trying to hurt us i'm
trying to kill him oh it'll be like that
famous scene from the movie where luke's
got the camera pointed up his nose and
he's like looking around he goes i think
you need a wide cam for that one he's
got a white cam and then he's like i
hear something tim do you hear that
what's who is there and then lugos hold
on and then he just unholsters the shine
arm and he's like don't move ah he's
armed don't move don't make me put it
down put it down he's running away
all right anyway what were you talking
about tim you're telling me a joke
uh no but moving on from that i'm
curious about uh uh i'm i'm
you you're probably pro 2a across the
board absolutely yeah let's talk about
guns the thing is i i know people who
never even owned a gun who are now they
have guns they've got ammo they're
stocking up and what's happened the last
couple years has woken up a lot of
people
and uh i'm not only my whole family
knows how to you know shoot and all of
that we do you know target practice
outside and at our gun club but i think
it's imperative to have the second
amendment the only thing keeping us
america and free right now is our second
amendment i was i was going to most
important where on the republican
political spectrum are you are you in
the mitt romney authoritarian status
sector or are you in the ron paul i
believe in freedom sector where's that
sword over there somebody where where on
what level are you uh let me just put it
this way um i'm endorsed by
let's say ron paul is a hundred mitt
romney is a zero on the freedom scale
what's your number i'm 100. okay i'm
100. i am a trump republican as i'd like
to say um i'm endorsed by president
trump proud of that by congressman gosar
by rick grinnell michael flynn mike
lindell
one of my favorite patriots so i love i
have the uh the america first movement
well trump i would i would say was like
a to my opinion my perspective like a
45-35 i mean he did he did the bump
stock ban he made a lot of incredulous
moves against the second amendment
personally oh you were talking only on
this no no in freedom all just freedom
in general i am a hundred percent pro-2a
and and as i say my my stance on it it
shall not be infringed i will never sign
any
legislation that would infringe
whatsoever now on will you work towards
repealing unconstitutional gun laws
absolutely that's you know but i think
people think they go oh the governor has
all the governor has all the power to do
everything you have to have legislators
working with you you know this is how
the system works so we'd have to and
arizona is a very free uh state when it
comes to second amendment i think is
probably the most free you know we've
had open carry texas didn't even have
open carry until last year
you're right right
lauren roberts arizona isn't she no no
she colorado yeah okay okay that was um
yeah what about heavy weapons
how big how do you feel like how how
powerful weapon do you think it should
be legal for someone to carry are you
actually asking like joe biden saying
you need to have a fighter jets if
you're really going to take on these
yeah like because people usually losing
to the taliban
next week
warships this is something tim quotes
from time to time
warships under the second amendment like
privateers i mean then the government
would conscript them to go fight for
them but like private citizens could own
warships so should a private citizen be
able to own a small nuclear device
nuclear bomb
rocket launchers not for nuclear weapons
i'm not for private rocket launchers
um
the
tough questions these are tough
questions i don't think i i am i am for
a you know there's probably any weapon
that any any gun i mean i'm i'm pro 2a
so i i don't know rocket launcher
is a rocket launcher a firearm
definitely it's a ballistic right to
bear arms
it is arms
and so this is an issue uh my my
attitude is private citizens should be
allowed to own rocket launchers
private citizens should be able to be
allowed to own bazookas well if you read
the second amendment it talks about you
know it's not about hunting and it's not
about target shooting right it's about
protecting against tyranny which well
it's it's it's about predicting
everything uh a free state it you know
uh it requires the people to i'm not
quoting but i'm saying it's it says you
know uh
can you who can verbally well it's a
well-armed militia and
i wanna i just wanna i wanna know
yeah i wanna read it specifically okay
i'll read it to you if you need it right
here
a well-regulated militia thank you being
necessary to the security of a free
state the right of the people to keep
and bear arms shall not be infringed the
reason i want to get it verbatim
is that
uh securing a free state what does that
mean well can you have a free state if a
bunch of bearers attack your city
no no of course there's a lot of them so
it's not about one thing it's about
everything and so there's been a lot of
people who have said it's specifically
about when your governor government
becomes tyrannical and i'm like no no no
no it's not specifically about that it
does include that it's also about if a
foreign adversary seeks to invade your
country and everyone's armed with the
teeth and they're like there's a gun
behind or if it if the foreign
corporation hijacks your monetary supply
and prints your economy into oblivion
you're that's threatening the security
of your free state right there what
happens if someone comes to your door
and tries to pull your family out and
put you in uh a quarantine camp
oh yeah that's when things go go reel
down this is well and i think this is
why the difference between australia
there's a million differences in america
and i think this is why we haven't had
more
strong of restrictions placed against us
because especially in the state like
arizona you know behind any door someone
might have a gun probably does you can
see the way the australian cops move too
they have no fear no fear yeah and it's
and what people need to understand it's
not an issue of assuming that
australians would be running out the
door and just firing wildly it's like
ian mentioned it's the fear when the
police broke down the door of briana
taylor's house you know the story about
brennan taylor her boyfriend fired
around in the direction of the door
striking a police officer in the leg
that was ruled justified and the charges
were dropped because if you break in
someone's door they could be armed
police in america know this and that
means regardless of what the law is they
have to contend with the fact there's an
armed population it doesn't mean that
there's going to be a bunch of
right-wing nut jobs taking over with
guns everywhere and screaming and you
know when when the government does
something wrong it means the government
is scared to make certain moves because
it's not about whether or not there's an
armed militia showing up at your door
and saying we hereby you know declare
it's about the fact that you tried to
enforce a red flag law this happened i
think it was in maryland and the guy
showed up with a gun fought the cops and
the cops had to shoot and kill him the
police understand that when you go to a
door you're not going to get someone
saying okay you might get a crazy person
or not even a crazy person a scared
person yes granny taylor's boyfriend who
just said someone's breaking into my
home fired hit the cop in the leg hey
that's america baby in australia again
like ian said the cops are fearless they
know they have nothing to worry about
there's a video out of australia where
they kick the door and they walk and
start grabbing people throwing them
around i'm like that can't happen here
in america to the same degree certainly
there are no knock warrants it will
never happen
there's their cops breaking into
people's maybe uncertainty they were
breaking into businesses a few months
ago and shutting them down but not like
that and not yeah like that yeah like
that there was video footage
i remember seeing video footage in new
jersey there was a lady who was in her
own private shop doing her own thing
and and she was uh making baskets i
believe if i believe the story was was
correctly coming off fresh of my mind
police officers literally broke down her
door because she was open at her place
of business by herself and told her to
shut down immediately
in north jersey a woman they they closed
everyone's businesses and said you shut
down end of story so she started live
streaming on facebook if you want to buy
any of my products here's what i have
the police showed up and they said ma'am
you need to shut your store down and she
said what are you talking about it is
shut down i'm closed and they go no
you're posting things online
yep so these things do happen
not like that i mean not to the scale
that it's no no no no no no no no
straight you're still right new jersey
has possibly the strictest gun laws in
the country you can barely even get a
gun in new jersey and if you can there's
crazy rules and i'm i'm pretty sure you
can't have a weapon in your place of
business i could be wrong unless you are
like a security guard and you've got
special certification it is difficult
and annoying and so the police in new
jersey are substantially less worried
about this is why it's so important to
vote for the right people oh yeah this
is this kind of stuff would not happen
in arizona although our governor shut
the state down twice
what was your take on 80 house
republicans yesterday voting for a
national
registry of of people who were
vaccinated uh one of those people was
what's that republican's name with the
den crenshaw den crenshaw and 80 house
republicans all voted for this how would
you vote on this particular issue when
it comes to a federal registry of of
people who are vaccinated and what's
your response to like that shaw for
voting for it you know dan crenshaw used
to be a really big hero and some ways i
think he is a hero i mean he served our
country valiantly and and i think he's a
great guy but some of the things he's
done politically i find uh alarming
that being one of them
that is a terrible idea now i'd be i'm
running for governor not i'm not running
for congress and so this is something
that would be handled at the federal
level of course yeah um
governor's more important i'm not for
that because as a governor you have the
authority to say we're not going to give
you the database we're not going to give
you the information or the data would
you comply as a governor if there was a
federal vaccine i believe our governor
did a comply with that in order to get
the federal money you had to agree to a
bunch of stuff new hampshire was one of
the states that actually declined the
money as a state would you be willing to
do the same thing as governor i would be
okay
if it means we're gonna give out well
here's the deal we did get a lot of
money for and and then they say it's for
coveted relief but not if i'm gonna have
to give up
my my citizens our citizens my fellow
citizens information private information
i'm impressed i i was expecting you to
dance around that that answer because
that's a tough one right well i mean
look what we're where it's getting us we
keep complying with the federal
government and all the things they want
and look where we are right now we're no
more closer to having our freedom back
and when do we stop and say enough is
enough we're not going to comply anymore
we're going to get off the federal teat
take your money and shove it or give us
the money but we're going to spend it
the way we want yeah
we're not going to do this that and the
other with your money this this is why i
said governor is more important a lot of
people pointed out that if ron desantis
were to run in 2024 florida would lose a
very powerful voice who's doing the
right thing for the citizens and so he's
better
working in florida because he's created
a safe haven essentially for people
they're flocking to florida like crazy
buying up property like crazy why
freedom yeah monoclonal antibodies for
free for people who are sick lowest
coveted cases the economy reopened a
while back and running
and you don't even realize there's any
restrict there aren't any restrictions
you're living free and that's what
arizona is going to be so i i tell
people too especially with the
legislatures in the states if you keep
thinking the federal government is your
path to fixing your problems you are
incorrect
ron desantis has proven that abbott to a
certain degree he's not perfect we'll
see if he's coming around a little bit
yeah maybe alan west will win because
he'll go you know he'll go much much
more like ron desantis and then uh when
it comes to a potential convention of
states whether it's a good thing or a
bad thing changes can be made if at the
state level people vote for we mention
this across the board and also to this
point district attorneys
very important big issue but i i think
and county attorneys and sheriffs i mean
it's we just have to be educated where
we're going
we have to be educated and i believe the
america first movement and we're going
to look at who's funding these people
who are their consultants
people are waking up to and you
mentioned some people who are still
asleep like the person you talked about
uh earlier a friend of mine yeah we're
not gonna name names but who's just
completely unaware of anything but i
think a lot of people are waking up and
who were never involved in politics
we're seeing him when we do events we
have a movement afoot in arizona we do
events that
thousands of people come out to we do
rallies and uh you know all kinds of
rallies and people come up to me and say
i am embarrassed to say this but i've
never voted before and i'm whatever age
50 something
and i'm voting i'm so worried about
where this country i've never been
politically involved but i know who's
running who their consultants are what's
behind them what they believe in so
there's a lot of exciting things
happening i'm actually very hopeful for
the future i was at a trump rally in
fort lauderdale back in 2016 and
every single person that i i talked to
had said like i'm either independent or
i've not voted before and i was like
you're at a republican rally and they're
like trump's different man it's you know
a lot of these people felt like mitt
romney like you saw the disdain that
this lukowski has for the mitt romneys
of this country and yet but trump
supporters do too they despise they do
too i do too and jeff flake and and john
mccain i mean we saw a lot of that rhino
and we have that in arizona we have a
deep deep swamp in arizona
and you know people go don't say rhinos
well that's what they are
actually i disagree um i think you're
the rhino
you want to think i'm the rhino you want
to but you know what you know what i
mean by that that the establishment the
republican party has always been this
feckless weak and you know in my opinion
well well ineffective and what's
happened now is a bunch of people
like trump like desantis and like you
have come in under the umbrella of
republican representing something with
principle and that's why i say i think
you don't want you to do well
i'm the conservative running i'm i'm a
conservative running as a republican
exactly because the republican party i
do believe is the party of trump it's
the trump republican party nowadays that
is america first and you know i talk to
people who are establishment and i
believe i can bring people together i
was a republican looking from the
outside in before i became a politician
thinking that the party you know we had
the rhinos and all of that but i i
thought the party was more
congealed than together now that i'm
running i realize it's so fractured and
and i believe we can bring this party
together but the establishment has to
realize america first is here to stay
and they should love that we've brought
people off the sidelines people who you
mentioned at the trump rally that i've
seen at our rallies who've never voted
before but this is what i want them in
this this is what i mean basically when
i see a ton of people who are not
republicans who are joining the
republicans but not because of mitt
romney mitt romney
is what what i think of what i think of
republican he repels people from the
party it is a an elitist corporatist
anti-american the koch brothers were all
about the open borders and you know
bringing in cheap labor to exploit even
bernie sanders opposed it trump was not
like the rest of them when he came in so
he was
a republican but just in name he
represent represented something new so
to be fair i would say now the party has
become the party of trump and now that
is what it means to be republican so now
i would say i understand when when you
refer to mccain and these individuals as
rhinos it's because they're the people
who don't actually represent the new the
voter base those who are joining the
party and those who are stepping up it's
huge what's happening though i mean it
is so huge what's happening it's very
exciting we go to events
and they say oh can you come speak at
this republican group or wherever we go
and they call us a couple weeks later
and they say we need to move the
location we we usually get 30 people we
have 130. and this is what we're seeing
everywhere we go people are off the
sidelines they're very excited about our
campaign
and we have a movement we have more
volunteers than any other campaign in
the in the country right now
it took us only three weeks to get our
signatures to get on the ballot
it usually takes to put that in
perspective and i'm i'm new to politics
so i'm like okay three weeks why did it
take us three weeks and they said carrie
no you don't understand
it normally takes candidates nine months
to get them
and they have to pay for them and
sometimes they don't get them at all you
got your you got your signatures in
three weeks it's never been done in the
history of arizona well i mean is that
people are excited uh
when's the election for arizona august
2nd that's the primary so of of next
year yeah you're getting you're getting
a head start huh we're acting we've been
running since june 1st and we've been
running like it was october of 22.
my staff jokes it's like we're running
like it's the last month leading up to
the uh general election do you have a
show sorry interrupt but do you like a
talk show you'd be great no i need one
yeah a weekly talk show on tv for 30
days i've thought about doing a podcast
so this is really interesting to watch
but i thought it was easier than this i
thought with just me and a camera and
you would bring somebody else in but
this isn't quite an what's the best way
to do it because it's not scripted you
you talk from your your heart you don't
talk from talking points there's nothing
scripted here thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you